all of us at the School of Life would
like to thank you from the bottom of our
hearts for helping us to reach three
million subscribers it's fascinating to
think that there are now more people
subscribed to this channel
than there are residents of Jamaica the
entire population of Fiji could
subscribe three times each and there
would still be more of us left over
together you have watched over a billion
minutes of the school of life thank you
for subscribing to our channel watching
our films exploring the big questions
and growing our collective emotional
intelligence this channel wouldn't exist
without your support your comments likes
and purchases from our shop all mean
that we can keep sharing what we love
with you to say thank you for all of
your support we'd like to give away some
of our best holiday gifts our great
thinkers set our relationship set and
our calm set to be in with a chance of
winning one of these you simply need to
like this video subscribe to our Channel
turn on notifications and comment below
which gift you would like a winner will
be chosen at random and we will contact
you in your youtube inbox to give you
the good news from everyone at the
School of Life we thank you your support
means the world to us
you